[Music]  [Music]  do you need a doctor  i am a doctor  i should have died years ago  people all over the world have my  disease from here  to find a cure  we have to push the boundaries take the  risks  [Music]  if you're gonna run  do it now  then you were found on a container ship  that washed up off a long island  what did you do to yourself doctor  i wish i knew  i went from dying to being more alive  than ever it worked  not exactly i have increased strength  and speed  some form of bat radar  what else can i do  [Music]  there are limits there has to be there's  something inside of me  who wants to hunt  and consume blood  we haven't had anything this good since  that thing in san  wants to francisco you hey uh dr michael  you and i should stay in touch  i'd do anything to save a life  but i don't know what i'm capable of  save lives you don't take them  are you here to heal the world  or to destroy it  i'm just kidding it's dr michael  morvious at your service  [Music]  you